and minimalists how do you prevent other
people's negativity from turning you-
whoa hey you got to cut those people out
or at least ask them to stop being so
negative around you I've had that with
family where yeah where they want to
constantly be negative and I'm like look
I love you I love having conversations
with you
but we have to find some room to be
positive hmm so let's focus on more
positive things because if we're just
gonna focus on negative things like I
have to step away from this because it
makes me negative you know I'll give you
a specific example when I did this hmm
I did with myself I found myself
especially when I was going through
those health problems I was I was I was
I get caught in that that downward
spiral of negativity and what was me
this is never going to be over and I
finally told myself literally out loud
in the mirror
Simon Marshall gave me this exercise
he's a therapist and he basically said
you know you have to have this
conversation with yourself and and what
I did was I said hey I can't be around
this version of you hmm I said it to
myself yeah and and it made me change my
own behavior because I said hey look I
can't be around this version of you and
if I can say that to myself yeah I
certainly should be able to say that to
someone else yeah and even if somehow
you can help them understand that like
even if it was me who was behaving this
way I wouldn't be able to be around
myself yes yeah yeah I try to help them
you know understand that all right
Tiana at the very bottom Ryan it's a
question for us how can we find non
negative people you can go visit and on
negative people calm email list well
that's actually that's a good segue I
mean a few places the community tab on
patreon is a great place to share your
experiences yeah also if you're in one
of the eight countries where we have
meetup groups minimalist org there's a
hundred free local meetup groups you
could find people there you know what I
bet either some negative people in those
meetup groups do though oh yeah and and
so it doesn't mean you're gonna find
perfect people and in these groups have
we cost yet on this episode I mean its
patreon Sean's thing no all right then I
won't cuss I'll just say it playlng okay
get off of social media if you want to
if you want to find negative you want to
find non negative people get off of
social media and start insert building
relationships other ways because I have
a have a feeling that a lot of the
negative and negativity that Tiana is
experiencing is coming from Facebook
it's coming from Twitter it's coming
from other places so many of our
negative relationships are birthed out
of what proximity mm-hmm right which is
just closeness to someone right so or or
convenience now yeah that's social media
all of a sudden people who were not
close to you they're now in your
proximity they're right there they're
literally right here on this glowing
screen yeah it doesn't get closer than
that right until it's been inserted into
some microchip in my head but until then
it doesn't get close to that so negative
relationships are birthed out of
proximity and convenience what else is
convenient well we happen to work next
cubicle over from each other we worked
in the same restaurant or retail store
yeah we we work at the same job these
negative relationships are often
relationships we feel that we have to be
around you can limit your time around
them so maybe the answer your question
is actually in the question itself how
do how do you identify let's just let's
let's take their word non out of here
Ryan if I were to read this question
again is how can we find negative people
that's an easy answer right yeah yeah
proximity and convenience well what's
the opposite of that we need to seek out
inconvenient relationships and if we
seek out inconvenient relationships ones
that there's a vetting process involved
what's that vetting well it means we
share similar values how do I identify
with my values are well you go to the
minimalists comm /ve there's a essay
right there that says how to understand
your values and you you take a look you
identify what your values are you start
to identify the values of other people
and if you value non negative
relationships then that's one of your
values it's gonna be one of your
structural values for our
oh boy dude you know this it's
interesting because I feel like
Michelle's question and Tiana's question
are kind of the same you know how do you
prevent others negativity from turning
you negative I mean that's that is why I
had to get off of Facebook it was
creating such negativity in my life
because I was in this phony world where
people are expressing recreational
outrage
therefore it made me want to push
against their recreational outrage to
the point where it was sticking with me
all day long and like I had to I mean I
had to identify like oh I'm I'm
constantly having these arguments in my
head because of Facebook and yeah so I
got off of there so uh you're what
you're saying here Ryan is your brain is
a domicile and you're going to let your
domicile you're gonna let people pay are
you gonna let people have access to it
rent-free the question is who do you
want to give rent-free access to this
domicile because there's only so much
space in there right
there's 24 hours in a day there's our
focus our attention can be spent only on
a finite amount of discrete bits of
input and you get to decide am I gonna
focus on the negativity am I going to
let the negative people free rent in my
head and if I am Who am I pushing out
yeah by giving those people with a free
rent